bonsoir et bienvenue ravie de vous
retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce soir
un insoumis dans le fauteuil du grand
témoin manuel broupard bonsoir
coordinateur de la France insoumise le
parti de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sous le feu
des critiques de l'exécutif ces derniers
jours le gouvernement vous accuse
d'activer les violences dans le pays à
Sainte-Soline notamment mais aussi dans
les cortèges sur les retraites alors
voulez-vous saper les institutions comme
le dit Emmanuel Macron et bien je vous
poserai la question tout à l'heure dans
la deuxième partie mais on va commencer
ce soir par le plan o la fin de
l'abondance nous oblige à changer nos
usages le président de la République a
fait toute une série d'annonces on va y
revenir premier touché par la sécheresse
les agriculteurs qui vont devoir
s'adapter voir changer complètement de
modèle alors l'eau à l'heure de la
sobriété c'est notre grand débat dans un
instant avec nos invités avant de
retrouver à 20h15 les parties pris de
nos affranchis la carte blanche de
Nicole Ferroni ce soir et puis Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
vous me suivez manuel Booba ça vous
regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
le lac de Serre-Ponçon dans les
Hautes-Alpes la plus grande réserve
d'eau douce d'Europe la carte postale
présidentielle était soignée aujourd'hui
pour le premier déplacement d'Emmanuel
Macron en région depuis la crise des
retraites un plan o détaillé pour gérer
les pénuries des mois et des années à
venir après la sécheresse historique de
l'été dernier bonsoir Pascal Lavergne et
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes députés
renaissance de Gironde agriculteur de
professions vous élevez des bovins vous
avez aussi fait du vin expérience qui va
être utile à notre débat bonsoir
Sébastien mairie et bienvenue vous êtes
agriculteur dans le Loiret président de
la FNSEA locale vous produisez je crois
sur 45 hectares des céréales maïs
blé-orge colza destinée à nourrir du
bétail je ne dis pas de bêtises
principalement et destiné à nourrir la
population humaine je fais de l'orge
pour faire de la bière je fais du blé
pour faire de la farine et je fais aussi
des céréales qui servent aussi à
alimenter et à nourrir le bétail et tout
ça ça consomme énormément
vous nous direz si vous êtes prêt à
changer de modèle ou pas bonsoir Xavier
le fleuve merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes responsable de l'équipe haut à la
Direction de l'Environnement de l'OCDE
enfin bonsoir Marc lemady bonsoir ravi
de vous accueillir vous êtes journaliste
économique des années au Parisien et
vous venez de publier une enquête très
fouillée sur les projections climatiques
France 2050 RCP 8.5 le scénario noir du
climat séché Albin Michel rcp8.5 c'est
quoi en un mot c'est le scénario le plus
pessimiste disons du GIEC à l'horizon
2100 ce qui nous mènerait à 5 degrés
d'élévation de la température ce qui est
le chaos climatique voilà ça fait peur
mais c'est utile pour prendre les
mesures drastiques nécessaires manuel
Bompard évidemment vous êtes le bienvenu
dans ce débat quand vous le souhaitez on
commence par planter le décor comme
chaque soir le plan haut du président
résumé en deux secondes c'est la nuit
blackovski c'est colle le chrono de
Blacko c'est parti
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir mon cher Stéphane
bonsoir bonsoir Myriam bonsoir à tous
Alors ce plot alors autant vous prévenir
manuel Macron n'a pas demandé à
Christophe Béchu de défendre un grand
projet de loi sur l'eau à l'Assemblée
dans les députés allez savoir pourquoi
il a préféré faire un plan qu'il a
présenté lui-même avec une cinquantaine
de mesures qui seront donc plutôt
installé par décret donc en fait on a
bien sûr au courant de 30 jours sans
pluie les 80% des nappes phréatiques
sous leur niveau faible mais c'est pas
nouveau dès 2015 le hennu tirait le
signal d'alarme en disant que en 2030 la
ressource en eau pourrait baisser de 40%
sur la planète or 2030 j'espère que vous
le savez vous aussi c'est le chiffre
fétiche du président de la République
dès qu'il a un objectif c'est 2030 on
l'écoute
ce plan haut donc avec sa cinquantaine
de mesures c'est avant tout un plan de
de sobriété d'efficacité pour l'eau dans
la durée
et je veux pour ça fixer un cap à notre
nation avec un objectif pour 2030 qui
est de faire 10% d'économie d'eau dans
tous les secteurs donc il y avait les
objectifs chiffrés mais il a aussi parlé
de la méthode évidemment donc la méthode
on la connaît en fait il s'agirait de
s'inspirer de la sobriété énergétique
dont elle a su faire preuve cet été avec
une réduction de 10% de la course
d'électricité on pourrait faire pareil
avec l'eau donc éviter en premier lieu
les gaspillages et la première source de
gaspillage ce sont les fuites dans les
canalisations on écoute le président le
deuxième grand axe c'est la lutte contre
les fuites et la modernisation de nos
réseaux
dans de nombreux territoires nous avons
des réseaux d'eau qui connaissent des
fuites très importantes à l'échelle
nationale on a un litre sur 5 qui est
perdu à cause des fuites un litre sur 5
ce qui est inacceptable vous vous rendez
compte mirame un litre sur 5 on a
l'impression que le président et
lui-même étonné quand il annonce
l'importance des fuites or en vrai il ne
peut pas être étonné parce que là non
plus c'est pas nouveau on écoutait de
voir Philippe souvenez le Premier
ministre c'était il y a 5 ans on
l'écoute difficile d'avoir une idée
précise de l'eau que nous gaspillons à
cause de ce mauvais état des réseaux
certains disent que en moyenne c'est de
l'ordre de 20% un litre sur 5 serait
irrémédiablement perdu alors le côté
positif c'est que ça prouve que le
président Macron s'intéresse depuis
longtemps à la question de l'eau en fait
ce qui est un peu gênant c'est en
revanche il y a toujours 20% donc il
disparaît dans les fiders qu'est-ce qui
va changer avec ce plan pourquoi ça va
changer il y a une question de moyen
évidemment donc je peux citer l'exemple
par exemple des communes ils sont 170 en
France ou plus de 50% de l'eau se perd
dans les canalisations à cause des
filles donc un budget va être consacré à
ça 180 millions par an pour vraiment
traiter l'urgence si possible avant la
sécheresse qu'on attend cet été mais il
y a aussi plus d'argent qui sera donné
aux agences de l'eau donc ça ça pourrait
être par exemple pour développer la
réutilisation des eaux usées on est très
en retard en France j'imagine que vous
en parlerez pendant le débat mais
l'annonce qui devrait avoir le plus
d'effets sur la sobriété c'est la
tarification progressive de l'eau donc
c'est une mesure qui existe déjà depuis
2013 sauf que très peu de communes l'ont
mises en place alors l'exemple consiste
souvent c'est celui de Montpellier vous
voyez comment ça se passe les premiers
mètres cubes d'eau se tondre on a besoin
pour l'alimentation l'hygiène à
Montpellier ils sont carrément gratuit
jusqu'à 15 mètres cubes et puis plus on
consomme beaucoup d'eau plus les le prix
de l'eau s'élève jusqu'à la fin ou ceux
qui ont consomme beaucoup pour je ne
sais pas piscine laver leur voiture leur
jardin finissent par le payer assez cher
et c'est plutôt une méthode efficace
parce que Dunkerque qui a été un peu
pionnier dans ce domaine qui fait ça
depuis 10 ans on se rend compte que la
consommation moyenne des foyers ABC et
puis que évidemment la surcharge sur
route pèse plutôt sur ceux qui sont gros
consommateurs bref vous allez pouvoir de
la pertinence de ces mesures mais on va
quand même laisser le mot de la fin au
président lui-même on écoute cette
tarification progressive et
responsabilisante c'est celle qui va
permettre d'assumer que l'eau est un
bien commun et d'organiser une
incitation à la sobriété dont nous avons
tous besoin l'eau est un bien commun et
le président a rappelé il va falloir la
partager donc le principe je pense que
vous êtes tous d'accord après comment
faire respecter le principe là il va
peut-être y avoir des voix merci
beaucoup merci Stéphane pour ce pour ce
billet Pascal Lavergne la philosophie
générale si on essaye de la résumer
c'est la responsabiliser la
responsabilisation de chacun c'est ça on
va faire des économies sur la
consommation va jouer davantage sur la
demande que sur l'offre d'eau c'est ça
l'idée de toute manière la réserve en
eau elle est ce qu'elle est on voit que
aujourd'hui la pluviométrie n'est pas là
peut-être que nous aurons des périodes
meilleures vous savez moi je suis
agriculteur depuis un certain nombre
d'années je vois effectivement des
variations de de pluviométrie annuelle
donc effectivement nous venons
d'enchaîner c'est ça qui est dramatique
nous venons d'enchaîner un été très sec
avec peu de pluviométrie dans ce qui
fait que le niveau des nappes a
fortement baissé et nous enchaînons avec
un hiver qui est également très simple
tarification progressive qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez je crois que ça a marché
manifestement à Montpellier c'est un bon
principe intellectuellement moi ça me ça
me convient ça permet de reconnaître que
on a un droit un peu universel à l'eau
mais que au-delà d'une certaine quantité
effectivement il faut peut-être la payer
plus cher ça permet de responsabiliser
moi je trouve que c'est pas mal il
faudrait pas qu'on débouche sur des
usines à gaz qui engagent les
collectivités territoriales à faire
beaucoup de frais administratifs mais en
tout cas ça me paraît être une bonne
chose vous avez le fleuve cette
tarification progressive est-ce qu'elle
est juste et équitable est-ce qu'elle
tient compte par exemple du nombre de
personnes parfoisées est-ce que elle
tient compte des des différences
sociales des uns et des autres c'est
compliqué c'est un sujet sur lequel le
C2 a pas mal travaillé on est sur une
comparer les bonnes pratiques dans
différents pays et on se rend compte que
la tarification progressive
intuitivement c'est une bonne idée en
fait on pourrait montrer que c'est une
subvention qui est mal
ciblée elle va bénéficier à des ménages
qui pourraient payer plus et en fait
elle prive les opérateurs publics ou
privés c'est pas le sujet du revenu qui
permettrait d'étendre le service et
d'améliorer le service pour tout le
monde pour que pour que la tarification
progressive fonctionne et soit ciblée il
faut collecter énormément d'informations
sur la consommation des ménages qui vit
derrière le compteur etc ce qu'a fait
Dunkerque mais ça a pris énormément de
temps pour monter le pour monter le bon
le bon modèle c'est assez compliqué on
peut penser qu'il y a des mesures qui
sont plus simples avec des tarifications
plus simples et des mesures sociales
ciblées un point sur lequel insister le
fait de pas payer en fonction quoi en
fonction du niveau de vie des ressources
le fait de pas pouvoir payer sa facture
d'eau c'est un problème de pauvreté
c'est pas un problème Dialo et donc le
meilleur moyen d'adresser ce sujet là
que je minimise pas c'est via des
mesures sociales et pas par la
tarification de l'eau donc la
clarification
en fonction de la consommation c'est
attention faut se bonne idée marque le
Mali tout à l'heure on disait plus vos
maîtrise etc vous vous faites des
projections climatiques notamment sur la
question de la sécheresse avant de nous
dire ce que vous pensez de la
tarification à quoi peut-on s'attendre
cet été alors cet été ça va être 2022
peut-être empire mais en tous les cas à
peu près l'équivalent de 2022 c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle le
président de la République annonce un
plan là le premier objectif du plan
c'est évidemment de passer l'été dans de
bonnes dans de bonnes conditions
type abricots pêche on parle de coupure
qui souffrent déjà qui enregistre des
baisses de rendement c'est évident mais
vous me posez la question de la
projection c'est pas moi qui fait les
projections sont les scientifiques qui
font les projections en gros pour avoir
une à peu précise plus 1,5 degrés de
réchauffement c'est 3 ans de séchage ce
qu'on a connu là en 2019
depuis 2019 vous rajoutez un demi degré
c'est deux ans supplémentaires donc à 2
degrés vous êtes déjà à 5 ans 2 degrés
en France on est déjà un 7 on y est dans
10 ans et vous rajoutez comme ça à 4
degrés vous êtes à 9 ans de sécheresse
bon ça c'est la première chose
c'est-à-dire qu'on va avoir des
sécheresses pluriannuelles et
deuxièmement il va y avoir une baisse de
la ressource en eau estimée entre 10 et
40% de baisse du du débit des fleuves
les réserves on estime que dans le pire
des cas 60% des réserves françaises
seront en dessous du seuil d'alerte de
manière systématique donc raréfication
de de l'eau quand vous dites que la
pluviométrie évidemment il y a une
variation
inter annuelle ou saisonnière mais la
ligne la ligne est extrêmement claire
donc ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'en
fait on va se retrouver dans une
situation où il n'y aura pas assez d'eau
pour tout le monde ça c'est la guerre de
l’eau je donne juste un chiffre qui a
été donné il y a quelques quelques jours
par le bassin de la Burgaronne qui est
le plus grand bassin c'est 25 millions
de personnes dans ce bassin gigantesque
de Laurent Garonne aujourd'hui il manque
200 millions de mètres cubes en 2050 il
manquera 2 milliards de mètres cubes 2
milliards de mètres cubes ça veut dire
que à peu près 6 millions entre 6 et 10
millions de personnes dans la
bourg-garonne vont manquer d'eau
vraiment manquer d'eau qu'il y aura plus
d'eau pour tous les usages donc il va
falloir la partager c'est évident alors
la partager comment il y a une solution
qui est le signal prix ça c'est la
tarification pour vous alors moi je
pense que c'est c'est pas tellement une
mesure sociale parce qu'effectivement
elle n'est pas ciblée mais c'est plutôt
une mesure anti-gaspillage c'est de
l'anti-gaspille plus vous consommez plus
vous payez cher donc évidemment les gens
qui ont les moyens vont continuer à
consommer la classe moyenne va être très
dissuadée de de remplir sa piscine
d'aller laver sa voiture tous les quatre
matins etc il y a plein de solutions
la grande mesure le reste on savait
qu'il fallait arrêter de gaspiller l'eau
réutiliser les eaux usées mais là la
tarification progressive étendue à
l'échelle du pays qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez j'y suis favorable j'y suis
d'autant plus favorable que notre groupe
parlementaire dans sa niche
parlementaire l'année dernière en 2022
avait fait une proposition de loi qui
reprenait exactement cette proposition
je trouve que c'est positif que
manifestement les lignes bougent puisque
à l'époque les députés notamment du
président de la République ne l'avez pas
voté même si c'est pas ciblé non mais
attendez je pense que ça va dans la
bonne direction bon je pense que ça va
dans la bonne direction et le modèle
Montpellier rein qui a été montré tout à
l'heure je vous informe si vous le savez
pas que la personne qui en est en charge
est le maire de Grabels qui a un maire
qui appartient à la France insoumise qui
a mis en place cette tarification
de l'agglomération Montpellier Rennes et
c'est le maire de la commune de Grabels
qui est à côté de Montpellier qui est
René Revol qui est maire de la France
insoumise qui est en charge de ce
dossier je pas ça pour faire de la
publicité je dis juste pour vous dire
dans la bonne direction je je j'en
prends acte je trouve ça positif
maintenant si on doit examiner le plan
dans sa globalité il comporte un certain
nombre d'insuffisance et aussi un
certain nombre de recules vous avez
donné tout à l'heure le chiffre de d'une
réduction de 10 % d'ici à 2030 il se
trouve que dans la mandature précédente
il y avait déjà un objectif chiffré qui
était une réduction de 10% des
prélèvements d'ici à 2025 donc là
l'objectif qui vient d'être annoncé
aujourd'hui malheureusement ça je m'en
satisfait pas vous voyez je prends les
points positifs et je pointe aussi les
aspects négatifs là c'est plutôt un
recul pourquoi parce que ces cinq
dernières années malheureusement rien
n'a été fait sur ce sujet alors vous
allez répondre mais je voudrais terminer
le tour de table Sébastien mairie on va
parler tout à l'heure du stockage de
l'eau et des méga bassines évidemment
comme agriculteur vous concrètement quel
impact a le manque d'eau aujourd'hui
avant de répondre sur le manque d'eau
mais vous m'avez pas interrogé sur les
filles sur les fuites mais les 1 litres
sur 5 moi en tant qu'agriculteur mon
réseau d'irrigation qui est présent sur
ma ferme les 1 litre sur 5 je suis
effaré je ne laisserai pas dans mon
réseau d'irrigation perte 20% du volume
en eau tout haut que je prélève pour
pouvoir irriguer et pour pouvoir avoir
une production de votre exploitation
parce que je surveille et j'utilise 100
% de la goutte d'eau et je valorise 100
% de céréales sont déjà menacées ou pas
par ce par ces sécheresses je vais je
vais vous répondre très positivement et
comme Monsieur Lavergne l'a dit on est
sur une irrégularité des pluviométries
on est dans le cadre d'un dérèglement
climatique aujourd'hui et à ce jour je
suis à plus de 150 mm dans mon
pluviomètre dos depuis le 1er janvier
2023 pour vous dire c'est satisfaisant
j'ai eu 22 jours certes au mois de
février sans eau mais le volume d'eau
qui est tombé les trois premiers mois de
2023 c'est supérieur aux trois premiers
mois de 2022 donc vous vous trouvez
qu'on en fait trop sur l'alerte il ne
faut pas faire non plus peur il ne faut
pas faire peur on est sur des
dérèglements climatiques avec des
volumes d'eau ce que je constate une
irrégularité des précipitations qu'on ne
connaissait pas avant mais on a des
forts cumuls d'eau à certaines périodes
de l'année et des manques pendant
d'autres périodes de l'année alors
pourtant le Président de la République
qui ont y viendra à parler d'un
changement même de modèle agricole et il
est prêt à accompagner les agriculteurs
pour ça mais d'abord on va rester sur
les particuliers il y a des symboles
dans cette guerre de l'eau qu'on espère
pas vivre mais mais qui risque d'arriver
malgré tout ce sont les piscines il y a
des départements déjà où et bien les
mers essayent d'interdire les permis de
construire on voit cela dans le détail
avec ce reportage de Marco pommier
alerte sécheresse dans les
Alpes-Maritimes depuis la mi-mars le
remplissage des piscines privées est
interdit dans le département des
restrictions en matière de consommation
d'eau de plus en plus fréquente en
France au pays de la faïence dans le Var
certains mers envisagent même des
mesures radicales plus de permis de
construire c'est un message plus parmi
de construire plus de piscine on stoppe
provisoirement de 3 à 4 5 ans interdire
la construction de piscine privée une
décision qui en pratique serait
difficilement applicable comment je vais
je vais refuser un permis vous allez
m'attaquer au tribunal et vous allez
gagner la piscine va exister et vous
allez en plus me demander des dommages
des piscines privées pointées du doigt à
l'heure de la sobriété énergétique et
face au changement climatique le débat
remonte à l'été dernier ce que demain
vous dites s'il y a trop de sécheresse
on ira pourquoi pas jusqu'à interdire
des piscines privées mais vous comprenez
que c'est l'absence d'action sur
l'écologie qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus utiliser l'eau si vous ne me
dites pas non je vous dis pas non face à
la controverse l'écologie se Julien
Bayou avait rapidement nuancé ses propos
d'autant que la filière des piscinistes
s'inquiète face au sécheresse et
restrictions à répétitions pour ce
patron de PME les piscines représentent
un tiers de son chiffre d'affaires c'est
très inquiétant on a on a l'ensemble des
entreprises du secteur ont fait des
investissements pour ma part j'ai acheté
un camion l'année dernière un engin
télescopique je me suis équipé et si
demain je dois ne plus pouvoir faire ce
type de projet qu'est-ce que je vais
faire de la dizaine de salariés qui sont
dans mon entreprise un débat économique
et politique qui dépasse le cadre de
l'écologie d'après ce sociologue pour
lui la polémique n'est pas fondée
vu qu'il ne consomme que 2% de l'eau et
que si vous voulez effectivement on peut
la faire diminuer cette part mais c'est
quand même extrêmement peu sur
l'ensemble par rapport au plaisir social
que ça crée au type de lien que ça
permet etc mais est-ce que c'est pas
plutôt en permanence l'agression contre
les riches qu'on trouve ceux qui n'ont
pas de piscine contre chacun des
piscines la piscine le symbole d'une
réussite qui s'est largement
démocratisée avec plus de 3 millions de
bassins privés la France possède le
deuxième parc de piscine le plus
important au monde juste derrière les
États-Unis
c'est anecdotique mais c'est aussi très
symbolique la question des piscines
est-ce que on a tort ou pas de se
focaliser sur cette question là si on se
focalise sur sa question des piscines on
a tort parce que effectivement comme l'a
dit l'expert qui s'est exprimé ça
ceci dit une piscine c'est 50 000 mètres
cubes d'eau qu'on voilà pour remplir sa
piscine pour des pour des questions de
loisirs je répète lorsque la ressource
en eau va être rare à ce moment-là on ne
pourra plus autoriser des gens à
consommer d'un coup 50 mm cube d'eau
surtout dans la région du sud de la
France
donc on ne pourra plus autoriser les
gens à remplir ces piscines c'est
évident puisque il faudra partager cette
ressource qui sera devenu extrêmement
extrêmement rare c'est symbolique mais
c'est important mais symbole c'est comme
le signal prix c'est important
évidemment mais si on parle que des
particuliers parce que pendant la
République n'a pas parlé de de
tarification sociale pour les
entreprises ou pour la culture il a
parlé pour les particuliers pour les
particuliers là effectivement la
consommation d'eau des particuliers 90%
ce sont les usages domestiques et là il
faut absolument effectivement changer
nos comportements d'abord pour moins
gaspiller et surtout moins consommer
mais malgré tout là le Président nous
annonce un plan qui est un plan par
rapport à l'urgence et par rapport à
l'ampleur de la crise climatique est un
plan petit bras parce que là il compte
sur quoi il compte en gros sur la bonne
volonté des Français en me disant bon
bah essayez de d'avoir des douches qui
consomment essayer de récupérer l'eau de
la pour arroser votre jardin etc c'est
pas comme ça
qu'on va régler la crise climatique si
on en croit les rapports
par exemple le rapport qu'une secte qui
date déjà de 2012 de Météo France qui a
l'air déjà de manière extrêmement
précise si on prend le grand rapport
explore 70 qui lui aussi parlait de
cette sécheresse etc ou si vous
consultez les rapports de l'inrae c'est
extrêmement clair ce qui nous attend et
donc par exemple une des mesures qu'il
faudrait prendre à mon avis c'est dans
les nouvelles normes de construction
imposées aux promoteurs immobiliers de
mettre en place des systèmes de
récupération
domestiques de l'eau c'est à dire que on
n'a pas d'un côté la douche et l'eau qui
part à la rivière et puis de l'autre
côté les toilettes on récupère l'eau de
la douche pour les toilettes bon ça me
paraît évident de même que ça me paraît
évident ils découvrent ce dossier se
rendre compte que pour les toilettes il
y a de l'eau potable ça ressemble à bien
aujourd'hui Xavier
les questions piscine elles sont
fondamentales ou pas petite remarque
j'avais pas d'opinion sur les piscines
mais j'apprends dans votre portage c'est
2 % de la consommation d'eau 2% c'est ce
qu'on peut imaginer gagner si on réduit
les fuites des sur les usages
géométriques les Francs si on les fait
passer de 20% à 10%. parce que les
agents géométriques c'est 20-26% de la
consommation d'eau passer de 20 à 10 %
des fuites vous économisez 2 % de la
commune donc on fait un gros focus sur
les fuites c'est 2% de la consommation
derrière la lutte pour le climat il y a
aussi la lutte des classes qui peut
arriver ça va être difficile à supporter
si dans 20-30 ans certains ont des
piscines et d'autres non avec avec des
étés caniculaires non
pas de problème pas de problème pas de
commentaires on les garde parce que je
voudrais dire par rapport à ça puisque
effectivement chaque goutte d'eau elle
compte chaque goutte d'eau que l'on va
économiser elle comptera on apprend
qu'il y a plusieurs sources on va dire
d'économie il y a le volet fuite écoutez
moi j'ai été élu local je suis toujours
élu local et élu dans un syndicat
d'adduction d'eau nous avons amélioré en
20 ans la performance de nos réseaux il
faut continuer dans tous ces syndicats
et l'annonce du plan faite par le
président qui va redonner des moyens aux
agences de l'eau qui pourront
subventionner de façon déplafonnée
ces réparations de fuite
nécessaire c'est entendu on va parler de
l'agriculture je vais vous montrer un
graphique un camembert que vous
connaissez bien sur les consommations
d'eau par secteur et vous allez le voir
c'est évidemment l'agriculture c'est
très net 57% de nos consommer en France
qui arrive en premier devant l'industrie
devant l'énergie devant les particuliers
et l'eau potable alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait il y a un peu un et en même temps
dans le discours d'Emmanuel Macron d'un
côté il a parlé des méga bassines il a
pas de suite dit le mot il a dit
rétention colinéaire il a parlé de
stockage et en même temps il demande une
forme de révolution aux agriculteurs
écoutez
est-ce que les filières d'aujourd'hui
sont encore adaptées au climat de demain
et je peux d'ores et déjà vous dire
je crois dans notre agriculture j'ai
montré qu'on puisse ans se bat pour elle
et on avance et je crois notre
souveraineté alimentaire mais il est
évident qu'on aura des territoires qui
va falloir reprocher vers d'autres
schémas de culture et d'autres schémas
agricoles qu'on a des productions
agricoles qu'on connaît dans certains
territoires qui vont sans doute migrer
vers d'autres territoires qu'il n'est
pratique pas aujourd'hui et qui va
falloir réinventer des modèles agricoles
dans d'autres territoires de notre
République c'est une évidence Sébastien
mérit changer de modèle agricole ça veut
dire aussi renoncer à certaines cultures
qui consomment beaucoup d'eau c'est
votre casque que vous y êtes presque
vous envisagez une autre manière de
penser votre métier
je vais dire mon métier l'utilité de mon
métier c'est de produire de
l'alimentation c'est de produire de
l'alimentation pour les Français qui
puisse s'alimenter avec une alimentation
de qualité et en quantité vous avez
évoqué la lutte des classes pour les
piscines mais si demain imaginez les
rayons des supermarchés qui sont vides
parce que en France on n'est pas capable
d'avoir une production alimentaire sur
nos territoires parce qu'on ne met pas
les moyens on se donne pas les moyens de
pouvoir produire sur notre territoire
soit en apportera notre alimentation
soit quand on aura un problème sur une
partie de la planète comme ça a été
révélateur la guerre en Ukraine on
manquera d'alimentation d'un oreillons
il est important ce clivage la question
de l'agriculture
l'intérêt de l'irrigation
il va falloir forcément transformer les
choses non il y a une certitude c'est
que les plantes pour pousser il en faut
de l'eau ça vous ne changerez pas le
modèle en revanche effectivement on peut
faire évoluer les modèles d'assolement
je crois que les agriculteurs ont déjà
engagé cela comment on fait par le biais
du plan protéine les agriculteurs font
peut-être moins de maïs c'est le cas
notamment dans les Deux Sèvres ça a été
répété par par le ministre de
l'Agriculture tout au long de ce
week-end tout au long de cette semaine
les agriculteurs sont quand même en
capacité d'analyser tout ça et de faire
évoluer les modèles donc faisons
confiance aussi à l'agriculture je ne
voudrais pas qu'au travers de ce plan o
ce soit un moyen supplémentaire de
jeûner de jeter le discrédit sur
l'agriculture rappelons que
l'agriculture c'est aussi un arbre
géopolitique énorme parce que c'est la
souveraineté alimentaire et la France
aussi que l'agriculture est accès à
l'eau pour pouvoir assurer notre
souveraineté alimentaire Marc Lomazzi
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça on voit
très clairement bien face à face et que
il va falloir bouger
si on est d'accord pour dire que on vit
une crise climatique absolument terrible
il faut un moment donné lire les
rapports du GIEC il faut écouter ce que
nous disent les experts les experts nous
disent l'agriculture
c'est en France le deuxième émetteur de
gaz à effet de serre derrière les
transports c'est le premier consommateur
d'eau
on dit par ailleurs qu'il y aura pas
suffisamment d'eau pour tous les usages
y compris pour l'agriculture et quand on
va parler du problème du partage on ne
pourra partager l'eau que si tout le
monde a fait un effort et que donc il
faut quitter un modèle avec agricole qui
est un modèle d'agriculture intensive là
vous parlez de nourrir les Français ça
c'est de la communication la réalité
c'est qu'il y a effectivement une
culture
paysanne qui nourrit les gens et puis
vous avez une agro-industrie qui est
extrêmement consommatrice d'eau qui est
extrêmement émetteur
et qui est destiné pour une large part à
l'exportation ce qui a fait d'ailleurs
la fortune les experts qui avaient
mandaté le ministère de la transition
écologique sur cette question ont rendu
un rapport pour dire que compte tenu des
éléments dont on disposait en matière de
projection climatique il faut
effectivement changer de modèle pour
organiser une espèce de deuxième grande
révolution agricole la première
révolution agricole c'est à la fin
rebondir mondiale il fallait nourrir les
Français les paysans ont retroussé les
manches et on nourrit la France pendant
des années aujourd'hui il faut passer un
autre modèle plus proche de
l'agroécologie moins consommateurs
allez-y concrètement on parle de
nouveaux systèmes d'irrigation de goutte
à goutte de nouvelles cultures il ne
faut pas opposer et opposer les usages
et opposer les modèles agricoles je vais
vous moi je vous parle en tant
qu'agriculteur vous parlez
d'aggroécologie banco moi je suis en
agriculture régénérative je suis en
agriculteur de conservation des sols je
sais mais en direct donc je rejoins vos
propos sur les agriculteurs quand on
parle d'économie depuis 20 ans ils ont
amélioré l'efficience de l'eau on
produit 30% de plus de matières
végétales c'est-à-dire 30% de nourriture
en plus avec la même quantité d'eau qui
a 20 ans donc on est déjà dans une
trajectoire d'économie et vous êtes en
fait dans une opposition à nous faire
croire sur un changement de modèle mais
aujourd'hui le modèle français le modèle
agricole français a depuis 30 ans fait
des efforts à évoluer et je ne peux pas
vous laisser dire ça alors je suis pas
persuadé qu'on puisse faire durant même
temps sur cette question là justement
c'est la question Xavier Lefebvre on a
on a d'un côté le président de la
République qui dit
clairement oui au stockage de l'eau au
réserves géantes il la redit avec ses
mots ça c'est une partie de son discours
et puis il y a aussi une projection dans
l'avenir vers un changement de modèle à
quoi peut-il ressembler concrètement
sans pour autant et bien mettre à mal
toute une toute une filière je pense que
change un modèle d'une certaine manière
on peut pas échapper mais c'est pas
forcément dans une logique de
confrontation et de il y a des
arbitrages qui vont être compliqués à
faire trois éléments le premier c'est le
secteur agricole est très différent très
divers et certains auront plus sa
capacité de d'évoluer de s'adapter que
d'autres et donc ça peut demander des
mesures d'accompagnement ciblées
deuxième élément de réponse les échanges
internationaux il faut la solution n'est
pas forcément au niveau national on fait
partie de l'Europe il y a des échanges
internationaux l'OMC aussi réfléchit à
ces questions là et met l'eau au cœur de
ces au cœur de ces de ces répliques
échanger les modèles de culture dur
aussi ou pas peut-être suivant les
régions suivant les territoires suivant
les pratiques je voudrais juste ajouter
un point qui est un petit peu décalé
dans ce dans ce débat tout le monde est
pour la sobriété pour utiliser moins
d'eau la question qui se pose c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de l'eau qui est de
l'eau qui a été économisée parce que si
on utilise cette eau économiser pour
augmenter les surfaces agricoles ou
cultiver des plans des cultures qui sont
plus intensives en eau il y a aucun
bénéfice pour la ressource alors je vous
donne le mot de la fin allez-y il y a
ceux qui disent et il y a ceux qui font
moi je vois évoluer l'agriculture depuis
35 ans parce que je me suis engagé
auprès de l'agriculture par choix
sincèrement je vois ce monde évoluer je
vois ce monde prendre en compte les
enjeux de société les messages que lui
envoie la société il est entendu ce
message et je peux vous assurer que les
agriculteurs seront au rendez-vous pour
faire mieux avec moins d'eau mais
sachant que pour faire mieux avec moins
d'eau il faut aussi être en capacité de
la stocker au moment où elle tombe et
j'ai un modèle que je pourrais vous
présenter à l'occasion d'une autre
émission qui est un modèle de la vallée
acceptable c'est très clair on va
continuer d'ailleurs à en parler des
méga mais sinon on va s'arrêter là c'est
un sujet énorme évidemment on va le on
va le traiter ici à la chaîne
parlementaire et ce plan de Christophe
bechus sera détaillé secteur pasteur
dans les dans les semaines à venir merci
beaucoup merci d'être venu débattre vous
restez avec moi manuel Bompard dans une
dizaine de minutes et bien les parties
pris de nos affranchis ce soir le
philosophe Pierre-Henri tavoyau va vous
interpeller sur la violence en politique
la lutte contre les arnaques des
influenceurs c'est voter ce sera dans le
bourbon express avec Thibault Enoc et
puis la carte blanche surprise de Nicole
Ferroni à découvrir à la fin de cette
émission mais d'abord on revient sur les
insoumis le parti de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
vous êtes le coordinateur accusé je le
disais et bien baptiser les violences
par le gouvernement mais pas seulement
par la droite également dans cette crise
des retraites regardées c'est dans
l'invitation de Stéphanie Despierre
si on vous invite manuel Bompard c'est
parce que votre mouvement la France
insoumise et sous le feu des critiques
de l'exécutif après les manifestations
contre les retraites et contre les
bassines lundi c'est le président de la
République qui vous accuse de saper les
institutions il y a un réel projet
politique mené par LFI qui tente de
délégitimer l'ordre raisonnable nos
institutions les outils institutionnels
mardi c'est le ministre de l'Intérieur
que s'est c'est à gauche pour qu'on
n'est pas un mot dans une question
d'actualité pour penser à tous ces
policiers ces gendarmes qui sont blessés
que s'est-il passé à gauche pour qu'on
aisse des policiers que s'est-il passé à
gauche pour faire alliance avec Monsieur
Mélenchon qui les insultent qui les
vomit et qui finalement fait honte à
tous les électeurs de gauche et le
porte-parole du gouvernement rien ne
justifie les violences jamais et ceux
qui en ne les condamnant que du bout des
lèvres ou en tentant de leur donner une
forme de justification
nosore ni la confiance de leurs
électeurs ni les institutions qu'ils ont
juré de servir et protéger manuel
Bompard vous êtes né dans la Loire il y
a 36 ans vous êtes député des
Bouches-du-Rhône numéro 1 de la France
insoumise vous avez un doctorat en
mathématiques et c'est vous qui avez eu
l'idée des hologrammes de la campagne de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon en 2017
réservée toujours dans l'ombre du chef
vous avez piloté ces deux campagnes
présidentielles et vous restez de ses
fidèles en décembre vous passez à la
lumière en prenant les commandes de la
France insoumise tolé en interne des
députés et figures de mouvement créé au
hold-up après votre désignation sans
vote vous avez dit le vote n'est pas
forcément l'alpha et l'oméga de la
démocratie l'objectif c'est d'être le
plus efficace possible vous pouvez nous
expliquer cette phrase un peu étonnante
mais il peut y avoir des votes il y en a
parfois dans certaines de nos instances
et certaines de nos structures mais
parfois notre mouvement y compris à
l'échelle locale comme à l'échelle
nationale il privilégie des formes de
décision qui sont davantage des formes
de décision de recherche du consensus
pourquoi parce qu'on n'est pas un parti
politique traditionnel qu'on cherche à
inventer une nouvelle forme vous
succédez aussi à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
comme député de Marseille il vous a
légué sa circonscription imperdables
depuis l'été dernier le premier des
insoumis n'est plus ni député ni chef du
mouvement mais il est là dans les
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites il est là à l'Assemblée il
déboule quelques minutes avant l'annonce
du dernier 49-3 et il est toujours là
quelques heures plus tard à la Concorde
pour protester alors manuel Bompard
dites-nous qui est le vrai patron de la
France insoumise
c'est l'huile patron non le patron
[Musique]
donc à la France insoumise il y a pas de
patron Jean-Luc Mélenchon a été notre
candidat à l'élection présidentielle à
trois reprises il a fait 22 % des voix à
l'élection présidentielle l'année
dernière ce serait une folie pour la
France insoumise de considérer qu'il
faut se couper de mélanger bon mais pour
le reste le mouvement de la France
insoumise il a des instances j'en suis
le corps ordinateur n'a-t-il pas nous en
est la présidente du groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale
on le voit il était là pour la motion de
censure il regrette rien je crois pas
mais ça vous lui poserait la question à
lui et mais contrairement à ce que
laisse son temps de votre reportage vous
savez il y a pas besoin on est des gens
suffisamment équipés d'un cerveau que ça
soit Mathilde panot moi-même ou d'autres
militants de la France insoumise pour
pas avoir besoin de quelqu'un pour tirer
les ficelles derrière donc on a
l'impression que ça lui manque mais pas
du tout mais écoutez Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais pourquoi mais parce qu'on est dans
une bataille la bataille sur les
retraites qui est la taille historique
ça fait on a des manifestations ça fait
40 ans qu'on a pas eu des manifestations
de cette importance on vit à un moment
je pense que tout le monde le réalise
qu'à un moment extraordinaire notre
histoire politique je rigolochon il
incarne une proposition politique de
recours
avec un grand plaisir
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à Emmanuel
Macron quand il vous accuse de se faire
fait sur les violences et même de saper
les institutions bah celui qui s'appe
les institutions pour l'instant c'est
Emmanuel Macron lui-même je vous
rappelle quand même qu'on parle d'un
texte de loi sur les retraites qui est
rejeté par plus de 70% de la population
par plus de 90% des actifs par
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
de salariés et quand même pas de
légitimité parlementaire puisque le
gouvernement a choisi l'article 49-3
pour faire en sorte que l'assemblée ne
puisse pas voter sur ce sujet et malgré
ça le président de la République passe
en force donc celui qui abime et c'est
pas parce que c'est légal que ça n'abîme
pas à nos institutions ce qui abîme nos
institutions c'est de vouloir passer en
force un texte de loi alors qu'il est
rejeté par tout le monde ça c'est
beaucoup plus dangereux pour les
institutions que les propos les actes
que peuvent avoir les parlementaires de
la France insoumise qui n'ont rien à se
reprocher du point de vue du respect de
nos institutions sur la question des
violences je voudrais vous faire
entendre ce qu'a dit le président de la
République aujourd'hui sur ce qui s'est
passé à Sainte Solène ce week-end
rien ne peut justifier la violence il y
a des gens qui venaient contester et qui
étaient là en famille qui d'ailleurs
Amel le lendemain ont tenu un moment
plus festif qui n'a donné lieu à aucune
aucun débordement mais vous avez des
milliers de gens qui étaient simplement
venus pour faire la guerre
c'est inacceptable la guerre à Sainte
Soline je crois que le Président de la
République
ignore que les milliers de gens qui
étaient là étaient là dans leur immense
majorité pour protester contre la
construction Sébastien je ne parlais des
militants les plus radicaux des
écologistes et je pense que c'est une
inversion qui est extrêmement dangereuse
parce que l'immense majorité des gens
qui ont participé à cette manifestation
était venu là pour protester
pacifiquement contre un projet qui fait
courir un risque sur le cycle de l'eau
on en a 37 minorité on les a vu armés
organisées les images en témoignent
bouclier de masque à gaz feux d'artifice
prêt en découdre avec avec les gendarmes
c'est pas la guerre qu'il cherchait je
ne sais qu'il faudra leur demander mais
en tout cas et moi je vais vous le
donner mon avis moi j'ai toujours dit
j'ai toujours été extrêmement clair que
moi je désapprouve les méthodes d'action
qui sont des méthodes d'action qui vise
à s'en prendre des individus je les
désapprouve extrêmement clair moi je
suis pas procureur
politique et vous me posez une question
et ma question c'est que je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ces méthodes mais ce qui
s'est passé à Sainte Soline dimanche a
été organisée par le ministère de
l'intérieur d'une manière qui était une
provocation et qui voulait qu'il se
samedi d'ailleurs que ce provoque des
incidences des incidents qui a provoqué
je pense que c'était interdite oui
d'accord et donc puisque la
manifestation était interdite j'imagine
que vous aurez retrouvé des barrages qui
empêchaient les gens de venir manifester
non il y en avait aucun puisque la
manifestation était interdite j'imagine
qu'il y avait des gens qui étaient
présents pour dire aux gens non la
manifestation est interdite ne venait
pas non il y en avait aucun la vérité
c'est que le ministre de l'Intérieur a
choisi une doctrine dans maintien de
l'ordre qui était une provocation il a
mis des gens autour d'un trou une
bassine où il y avait rien à dégrader
rien à casser et il a poussé à la
fronton or je rappelle que la
responsabilité gouvernement est
responsable de ce qui s'est passé à
Sainte-Soline oui bien sûr je rappelle
que oui oui je le crois je rappelle que
la responsabilité du ministre de
l'intérieur c'est à la fois de protéger
les personnes qui travaillent sous sa
responsabilité en l'occurrence ici les
gendarmes et de garantir un certain
nombre de liberté constitutionnelles
comme la liberté de manifester j'observe
que dans ce cas de figure là aucun des
deux objectifs que doit être celui du
ministre de l'interne ont été remplis
parce qu'il y a des gendarmes qui sont
blessés et il y a des manifestants qui
n'ont pas pu faire valoir leurs droits
fondamentales et qui sont qui sont
blessés voire très gravement blessés
pour ça donc
le SAMU qui doit partir et le Gérald
Darmanin c'est une évidence n'importe
quelle démocratie du monde après ce qui
s'est passé samedi le ministre de
l'Intérieur aurait assumé sa
responsabilité ce serait parti le SAMU
récuse avoir été obstrué dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions et la manifestement été
tenu à l'écart de la zone de danger ce
sont les règles est-ce que pour vous la
polémique est close ou non pas du tout
d'abord c'est pas le SAMU vous savez que
des journaux ont publié des
enregistrements qui disent les choses de
manière extrêmement claire alors tu as
déjà
aucun aucun des enregistrements qui ont
été publiés n'ont été rectifiés non pas
du tout ce qui s'est tenu dans ces
enregis reste tout à fait valable et
véridique oui mais aujourd'hui le
scénario probable puisque le SAMU c'est
exprimé c'est que il n'avait pas le
droit d'intervenir parce que les règles
l'en empêchaient parce que c'était une
zone de danger bah ça c'est tous les
obser en permanence par les vous pouvez
si vous voulez défendre un point de vue
qui est celui du ministère de
l'Intérieur ah non non je vous réponds
bah oui sauf que là
mais sauf que moi il y a une enquête moi
ce que je vous dis madame c'est que par
exemple il y avait des observateurs de
la Ligue des droits de l'homme qui était
présent sur place et qui ont dit qu'il y
avait une tout à fait une possibilité
pour que les services de secours
puissent se rendre sur place et pouvoir
prendre en charge les blessés et que
manifestement il y avait des ordres de
des personnes qui étaient sur place et
qui s'occupaient du dispositif de
maintien de l'ordre pour leur dire de ne
pas y aller et ben je pense quand même
que c'est mérite d'être souligné et
l'enquête a été ouverte et notamment des
plantes déposées par les familles de ses
victimes il est temps de passer à autre
chose à dire en substance Emmanuel
Macron aujourd'hui tout ne peut pas
s'arrêter est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec l'idée que malgré la crise de
retraite les réformes doivent se
poursuivre non
c'est une manière d'essayer de dire bon
allez rentrer à la maison la
contestation est terminée on va passer à
autre chose mais pour ça
il faut quand même pour les Français
leur offrir un certain nombre de
réponses il y a beaucoup de réponses à
apporter sur l'eau on n'était pas obligé
d'attendre aujourd'hui pour le faire
d'ailleurs nous ça fait depuis des mois
et des années qu'on propose d'apporter
des réponses sur la question de l'eau
sur la question du pouvoir d'achat il y
a beaucoup de choses qu'on peut faire
mais si on veut pouvoir les faire très
rapidement il faut sortir de cette
situation et pour sortir des entretiens
de manière extrêmement simple c'est de
retirer le texte le Conseil
constitutionnel va s'exprimer le 14
avril prochain s'il valide les 64 ans
est-ce que vous respecterez sa décision
mais je respecterai sa décision mais je
contesterai la pertinence de ce projet
je continuerai donc vous appellerai à
manifester bien sûr mais attendez mais
c'est pareil c'est quand même
extraordinaire c'est pas parce que le
Conseil constitutionnel prend tel ou tel
décision qu'on a plus le droit de dire
qu'on n'est pas d'accord avec un projet
de loi si contester la démocratie c'est
ça alors oui je conteste la démocratie
moi j'ai jamais contesté la démocratie
vous vous ne le dites pas mais j'entends
dans la parole du président de la
République que les manifestations
deviendraient en quelque sorte
illégitime mais pourquoi les gens sont
opposés à cette réforme dans l'immense
majorité ce qui est légitime c'est de
passer en force on verra c'est
extrêmement mobilisé constitutionnel
mais si le Conseil constitutionnel juge
en droit il y a dans ce texte et dans la
méthode qui a été utilisé de nombreuses
raisons pour retoquer ce texte de loi
s'il ne le fait pas il ne le fait pas
mais ça n'empêchera pas la mobilisation
de se poursuivre jusqu'au retrait de ce
texte de loi c'est l'objectif que ce
sont fixés les manifestants et les
manifestants on verra ce qu'il en est
déjà le 14 avril et comment évolue ce
mouvement social je rappelle qu'il y a
une nouvelle journée d'action à l'appel
des syndicats jeudi prochain la Haute
Autorité de Santé a préconisé la levée
de l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants et le gouvernement va suivre
cet avis c'est la fin du vaccin covid
obligatoire pour les soignants est-ce
que vous saluez cette décision bien sûr
puisque vous vous rappelez peut-être
qu'on avait déposé un texte de loi au
mois de novembre dernier la France ins
dans notre niche parlementaire qui
d'ailleurs avait une majorité de députés
pour la voter le gouvernement avait fait
volontairement durer les débats pour
empêcher à ce texte d'être voté donc
bien sûr je pense qu'on aurait dû le
faire avant je rappelle que la France
est je crois le dernier pays d'Europe
qui a maintenu cette obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants et je pense
qu'il est nécessaire d'y mettre un terme
le plus rapidement possible ça reste
recommandé vous dites aux soignant qui
travaille à l'hôpital de se faire
vacciner tout de même vous le
recommandez le vaccin mais moi j'ai
toujours dit les choses de manière
extrêmement simple mon opposition c'est
une opposition à l'obligation nationale
et c'est une opposition au fait que des
gens se soient retrouvés du jour au
lendemain sans emploi parce qu'il ne
voulait pas se faire vacciner on va
terminer avec une photo de votre
camarade François Ruffin si Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'était pas candidat en 2027
c'est une hypothèse il y a pas du tout
encore dit ce qu'il allait faire et on a
l'impression voilà l'idée de ne pas se
représenter n'est plus du tout aussi
clair dans sa tête mais s'il n'était pas
candidat ce qui ferait un bon candidat à
la présidentielle et il y en a plein
François Ruffin
comme d'autres feraient des très bons
candidats à l'élection présidentielle et
on a la chance d'avoir dans notre groupe
parlementaire des gens qui sont des gens
très grande qualité mais vous
reconnaîtrez qu'en 2023 c'est peut-être
pas le moment de désigner notre candidat
pour l'élection présidentielle de 2027
donc moi je suis fier d'appartenir à un
groupe politique dans lequel il y a des
figures de grands talent qui sont en
capacité de nos représenter la prochaine
fois mais on prendra un petit peu de
temps pour décider qui sera la personne
qui nous représentera certes merci
beaucoup vous restez avec moi manuel
Bompard c'est l'heure à présent
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris ils vont vous faire réagir
j'en suis sûr allez venez on vous
accueille tout de suite Tibo inok bien
sûr pour le bourbon Express Nicole
Ferroni sa carte blanche à la fin de
cette émission et Pierre Henry tavoyau
on commence par le bourbon express du
collège de philosophie que vous présidez
bien sûr bonsoir à vous Bourbon Express
comme chaque soir l'histoire du jour
Thibault inox c'est une histoire
d'influenceurs halte aux arnaques ça y
est c'est voté oui ce soir je vais vous
raconter l'examen de la Loi sur les
influenceurs aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
vous allez voir les députés nous ont
surpris c'est vrai que d'habitude dans
l'hémicycle on aime bien citer de
grandes personnalités Victor Hugo Simone
Veil aujourd'hui on a entendu des noms
très différents
pour la première fois dans l'hémicy
c'est que l'on débattait donc de la
régulation de ces influences faire une
proposition de loi porter par un tandem
lui aussi inattendu un député socialiste
Arthur de Laporte et un député
Renaissance Stéphane vogeta main dans la
main pour un combat transpartisan alors
pour l'occasion ils ont même tenté de
jouer les influenceurs eux-mêmes à leur
façon en faisant de la pub pour ses
débats regardez vidéo postées sur leur
compte Twitter hier
rendez-vous avec les influenceurs
certes mais travailler leur sujet ils
ont ainsi auditionné des influenceurs
avant le passage de la loi dans
l'hémicycle et visiblement il en est
resté quelque chose regardez
bref mes bébés par rapport aux lois des
influenceurs franchement c'est trop bien
ce qu'ils ont fait moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec eux parce
qu'en fait moi avec mes réseaux j'ai
fait tellement de conneries comme Maëva
Ghennam qui incarne pour beaucoup les
dérives de l'influence commerciale
faites attention à la loi qui arrive
vous le voyez derrière cette apparente
légèreté s'est en réalité un
avertissement qui lançait à tout un
secteur alors justement sur le fond
quand il voter les députés alors
l'objectif du texte aujourd'hui voter
aujourd'hui éclaire un maître fin à la
loi de la jungle qui prévalait
jusqu'alors et empêcher les dérives il
ne s'agit pas d'interdire le métier
d'influenceurs mais de l'encadrer
premier point ce nouveau métier n'avait
pas de définition juridique c'est
désormais chose faite deuxième point les
députés ont décidé d'appliquer à ces
activités le droit a déjà existant pour
la publicité la promotion pour l'alcool
et les jeux d'argent seront assis
encadrés les influenceurs devront aussi
intégrer des messages d'avertissement
pour les risques en matière de santé
pour les produits gras ou sucrés par
exemple ces points étant actés certains
ont demandé à aller plus loin et
formuler de nombreuses interdictions
mais l'option n'a pas été retenue
écoutée pourquoi la position est de
faire en sorte que les influenceurs
soient soumis strictement à toutes les
règles toutes les mêmes règles que les
autres canaux de publicité en ligne il
n'y a aucune raison d'interdire
seulement aux influenceurs des pratiques
qui seraient parfaitement légales dans
les communications sur Internet la
publicité des papiers la télévision ou
encore la radio
alors certaines interdictions ont été
quand même votées non oui deux formes de
publicité très courantes dans ce secteur
seront interdites pour la chirurgie
esthétique d'abord et puis pour les
crypto monnaies sauf à de rares
exceptions pour le reste les
influenceurs pourrontent influencer mais
ils devront ils devront être plus
transparents tout placement de produit
devrait être signalé par un bandeau tout
comme le nom du fournisseur par ailleurs
si l'image est retouchée aussi un filtre
est appliquée là aussi cela devrait être
signalé des amendes sont prévues en cas
de non-respects de ces obligations et
les plateformes devront retirer les
contenus qui ne les respecter pas la loi
a été adoptée à l'unanimité en fin de
journée et avec ce vote la France
devient le premier pays en Europe à se
doter d'un cadre en la matière et à
sortir du flou voilà les loulous vous
savez tout merci merci Thibault pour ce
point très complet alors on va
maintenant piquer un peu plus manuel
Bompard avec votre chronique ce soir
Pierre Henri vous vouliez revenir sur la
thématique de la violence politique qui
défrait l'actualité oui mais en faisant
un peu l'inverse qu'on a ce qu'on fait
d'habitude c'est on de passer de la
pratique à la théorie parce qu'on
politique la politique n'est jamais la
violence n'est jamais gratuite elle a
toujours une intention un but une
stratégie et c'est ça qui m'intéresse
vraiment c'est d'essayer de comprendre
ce qu'il y a derrière alors vous vouliez
parler deux exemples celui qui défrait
le plus l'acronie ce sont les Black
Blocs Black Bloc c'est pas un mouvement
c'est une stratégie c'est une stratégie
de l'anarchisme radicale quelle est la
stratégie dite du coucou c'est on comme
on est très minoritaire on utilise des
mouvements de manifestation de masse
pour faire en sorte de se les approprier
et de faire dégénéré ces mouvements dans
une violence mais pourquoi cette
violence c'est l'anarchisme radical dont
la thèse peut être formulée de manière
extrêmement simple c'est un ordre face à
un ordre plus exactement qui produit de
désordre il faut du désordre qui
produise de l'ordre l'ordre qui produit
du désordre c'est l'état c'est le
pouvoir et ses alliés capitalistes
pourquoi il produit des ordres parce
qu'il fait du c'est un fauteuil de
trouble dans nos vies individuels il
nous contrôle dans la vie politique la
conquête du pouvoir dans la vie
internationale donc c'est absolument un
supportable et il faut donc un désordre
qui puisse produire de l'ordre et c'est
pour ça que dans les queues de
manifestation et bien on s'en prend aux
expressions de l'État ou du capitalisme
les banques etc et ça ça produit
effectivement des dégâts assez
importants en fin de cortège deuxième
exemple deuxième exemple je savais pas
mais voilà la France insoumise c'est
essayer de comprendre ce qu'il y a
derrière la stratégie du coup d'éclat
permanent qui celle de votre partie qui
est au-delà aussi basé sur une théorie
celle de Chantal mouf philosophe belge
tout à fait intéressantes et très clair
qui s'inspire elle-même de deux penseurs
d'un côté et gramshee de l'autre car
Schmitt alors c'est pas un penseur
habituel de la gauche c'est plutôt un
penseur qui flirte avec le parti nazi
mais qui a une idée à sa importante qui
consiste à dire que au fond la politique
c'est le rapport ami ennemi c'est ça le
clivage politique et qu'il faut se
méfier du libéralisme le libéralisme on
dort un peu tout le monde dans la
négociation dans le consensus et fait
oublier qu'il y a un grand clivage
politique le clivage entre les élites et
le peuple les élites n'ont qu'un but
c'est de défendre leur propre intérêts
le peuple doit se défendre à l'égard de
ses élites et donc il faut pratiquer une
politique agonistique voilà le terme
technique agonistique ça veut dire du
conflit constamment le coût d'éclat
permanent le coût de de conflits
permanent il faut pas négocier il faut
être en désaccord et en dissensus
perpétuel le deuxième la deuxième
référence c'est grave chill la lutte
pour l'hégémonie culturel c'est plus
connu c'est l'idée que il faut pas
laisser au libéralisme qui possède les
médias les l'accès à la domination
culturelle mais il faut précisément
conquérir que l'agenda soit constamment
saturé par précisément les idées de ce
lutte de cette lutte populiste entre les
peuple et les élites je rappelle que
Chantal Moov veut fonder le dit
clairement comme ça un populisme de
gauche cette dernière stratégie pour
vous c'est ça qui fait monter les
tensions ça fait monter les tensions
mais le diagnostic de départ n'est pas
du tout à prendre à la légère diagnostic
est assez juste nous manquons dans notre
pays dans notre démocratie d'un
affrontement politique idéologique clair
voilà il faut le dire les parties sont
quand même tous un peu mous la France
insoumise n’échappe pas totalement
idéologiquement c'est un peu mollasson
dans la mesure où on essaye d'avoir une
idéologie la plus belle possible pour
ratisser le plus large possible et donc
de ce point de vue là oui il y a la
conflictualité pour la conquête du
pouvoir mais très peu de perspectives
dans l'exercice du pouvoir et si vous me
permettez ça me pose une question vous
pouvez l'adresser directement justement
j'ai confronté ces deux techniques de
très différentes parce que l'une vise à
détruire le pouvoir tandis que l'autre
vivrait conquérir le pouvoir
ma question est très simple quand on
s'appelle les insoumis et qu'on arrive
au pouvoir qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
Black Blocs
on fait en sorte de pas les laisser
perturber des manifestations qui sont
des manifestations spécifiques pardon la
police charge mais il y a plein de
méthodes de maintien de l'ordre pour
faire en sorte qu'on n'est pas besoin
d'en arriver là pas ça les Black Blocs
oui bien sûr d'accord puisque tout le
monde dit qu'on sait qui c'est si vous
savez qui c'est vous pouvez les
identifier par exemple d'accord donc
feriez mieux je pense je pense que par
rapport à Monsieur dark je pense que par
rapport à Monsieur Darmanin en terme de
technique de maintien de l'ordre on
ferait beaucoup mieux oui bien sûr mais
bon mais avec une police parce que quand
vous dites c'est vrai la police tue mais
là c'est pareil si vous voulez le
problème le problème combien de temps on
a pour débattre de ça
sérieusement de ces sujets il faut faire
en sorte de cesser les caricatures je
veux dire nous on n'a jamais dit que
l'ensemble des policiers tués ben il est
vrai il existe des cas effectivement où
la police tue c'est une évidence et la
question est de savoir si c'est
proportionné ou si c'est pas
proportionné bon il y a des cas où ça
allait pas et il y a une déontologies
qu'on demande qu'elle soit respectée et
parfois il y a des policiers très
respectés qui font pas bien leur travail
et ben on les dénonce on les couvre pas
comme le fait monsieur Darmanin et puis
des fois il y a des policiers qui font
bien leur travail et dans ce cas là on
leur dit bravo et on leur dit merci au
cheval juste avoir un petit peu de
nuance je sais pas si c'est peut-être
trop compliqué dans le débat politique
aujourd'hui mais je pense que ce serait
très utile pour notre démocratie parce
que
allez il vous reste allez un peu moins
de 3 minutes vous dit de quoi je vais
parler vous vous parlez ce soir d'un
fléau qui touche tout le terre et toi
oui exactement je voulais vous parler de
cette gigantesque Marinoise qui frappe
actuellement le territoire français
alors pour ceux qui se souviennent de la
catastrophe de l'Erika en 99 là on est
au-delà de l'Eric catastrophe on est
vraiment sur un erikaakhlysme puisque
c'est une marée noire qui ne touche pas
que notre côte maritime mais vraiment
tout le territoire français et qui donc
englut tous les petits êtres qui s'y
trouvent alors je sais vous allez me
dire ah bon
une marée noire est-ce que l'État a
débloqué des moyens pour y faire face
évidemment ce sont devoir de nous
protéger donc l'État a dépêché sur la
totalité du territoire français 50
personnes munies de petites cuillères
afin de
enlever comme ça le mazout pour sauver
les petits êtres qui s'y trouvent alors
je sais vous me direz pardon Nicole mais
est-ce que pour vraiment des millions de
tonnes de mazout est-ce que des
cuillères c'est pas un peu peu est-ce
que des pelleteuses ne seraient pas
mieux en quoi effectivement les millions
d'êtres du territoire que ce soit des
mouettes ou des marmottes ne serait pas
sauvé parce que c'est pas avec 50
cuillères qu'on va sauver des marmottes
oui surtout quand les marmottes sont en
réalité des marmots et que la marée
noire dont je vous parle et qui affecte
notre territoire est en réalité celle de
la pédocrinalité en ligne car ce que je
viens de faire est une métaphore et en
la matière la France détient un triste
record puisque la France est le deuxième
pays européen hébergeur de contenu pays
de Bordeaux graphique pardon le
quatrième pays au monde c'est à dire que
nos serveurs nos plateformes internet de
notre pays héberge un volume record de
photos et vidéos montrant des abus
sexuels sur des enfants et ça c'est un
podium très moche vraiment dont on se
serait bien passé mais c'est là c'est un
podium qui s'explique puisque face à la
marée noire de ces contenus affreux
l'État français ne compte pour s'y
opposer que 50 agents de police
judiciaire du formidable au crvp office
central de la répression des violences
aux personnes c'est à dire que pour
faire face à sa propre marée noire
l'État français n'a que 50 petites
cuillères là où le Pays Bas compte 150
agents le Royaume-Uni en a 350 impliqués
sur ses seules questions de pédo
criminalité alors vous me direz Nicole
qu'est-ce que la France doit faire alors
ma première suggestion c'est évidemment
donner l'heure des moyens sauf que qui
dit moyen dit pognon et quand on va un
petit peu la crispation sur la réforme
des retraites on se dit quand la la le
pognon c'est pas le premier réflexe là
en ce moment dans le projet du
gouvernement mais c'est pas grave parce
que moi j'ai une astuce gratuite pour le
gouvernement à qui je dis si vous ne
voulez pas donner des moyens pour sauver
les enfants et ben vous pouvez leur
donner des mots et ça les mots c'est
super pourquoi parce que ça ne coûte
rien mais c'est très puissant et là par
exemple ce qui serait très puissant ce
serait que dans les jours qui viennent
en amont du prochain Conseil de l'Union
européenne et ben la France par
l'intermédiaire de son gouvernement ça
peut être madame borde monsieur Darmanin
madame cobel et Ben se prononce
publiquement en faveur du projet de
règlement proposé par la commissaire
européenne il va Johansson alors c'est
un projet de règlement qui contraindrait
vraiment les plateformes Internet les
fournisseurs les opérateurs à détecter à
retirer à signaler les contenus
pédopantographiques et si la France
c'est pas grave elle est tombée et si la
France prenait publiquement cette
position forte pour un règlement fort et
mal serait donc le tout premier pays
européen à le faire et là on serait
enfin fier de la voir sur un beau podium
pour défendre les enfants contre vents
et marée noir
je connais pas le projet directive en
question mais si j'en croise que vous
dites ce serait une bonne idée mais pour
autant je pense qu'il faut pas évacuer
la première piste aussi
dans la police judiciaire parce que on
parlait tout à l'heure de doctrine et de
politique de sécurité on sent bien qu'il
y a une volonté de faire du chiffre donc
d'investir dans des effectifs qui sont
présents sur le terrain et que les
effectifs d'enquête c'est notamment le
travail de la police judiciaire c'est le
cas dans ce sujet mais c'est sur le cas
sur plein d'autres sujets sont souvent
les parents pauvres alors que c'est là
où il faudrait mettre les moyens pour
démonter des réseaux c'est ça la police
donc vous voyez y compris en matière de
sécurité si on veut sortir des
caricatures on peut avoir des débats
entre différentes orientations
politiques il y a pas d'un côté ceux que
ça intéresse pas ou quand même pas la
police et de l'autre qui sont les
meilleurs partisans de la police c'est
plus compliqué que ça on
rrête là je remarque que cette fois-ci
il y a l'art de la nuance et le culte de
l'Union c'est pas du Chantal mouf mais
c'est pas vrai la conflictualité
n'empêche pas la nuance
on va s'arrêter là je sais pas si c'est
un oxymore ou si c'est une dissertation
de philosophie c'est pour ouvrir la
porte si on l'écoute et ensuite on peut
débattre sérieusement en tout cas merci
beaucoup d'avoir été votre invité
pendant cette heure de direct Thibault
Enoc à très vite les affranchis grand
merci rendez-vous les amis quand vous le
voulez la semaine prochaine un peu plus
tard peut-être je t'apprécie même très
belle soirée documentaire qui commence
maintenant avec Jean-Pierre Gratien bien
sûr à demain
[Musique]